spätsommer im wendland erntezeit wie
jedes jahr
doch dieses mal ist alles anders
elf jahre hat landwirt stefan röpke sein
getreide ökologisch angebaut
er hatte sich ganz bewusst für bio
entschieden
doch jetzt setzt er aus einem
gerstenfeld wie der chemie- und
kunstdünger ein leicht gefallen ist ihm
das nicht
wie kann ich für für 25 euro und doppel
sender biogetreide erzeugen wenn ich nur
zwei tonnen ernten dann kommt da einfach
nicht warum das deckt nicht mal das
deckt nicht meine kosten
das bisschen bio premier haut das fand
ich heraus passiert einfach
rund 80 hektar bewirtschaftet er seinen
hof typisch für die region im wendland
im bundesland niedersachsen gibt es
viele biobauern doch stefan röpke musste
wie seine kollegen mit niedrigen preisen
und strengen bio bestimmungen kämpfen
selbst als dies denn seine ernte
vernichtet haben war spritzen
wir haben letztes jahr acht hektar
überhaupt nicht gern das war ein
totalausfall war nicht mehr geerntet
durch das kompensierte das muss einfach
das muss einfach irgendwo herkommen das
geld so dass
das bisschen was ich an eu-subventionen
für die für den biolandbau bekomme das
gleiche nichts aus
er ist kein einzelfall das thünen
institut in braunschweig hat die
situation der biobauern untersucht
hiltrud nieberg ist
agrarwissenschaftlerin sie hat
herausgefunden dass in den letzten zwei
jahren von zwei bauern die auf bio
umgestellt haben einer wieder aufgehört
hat und das obwohl die landwirtschaft
eigentlich grüner werden soll
wir haben im konventionellen landbau
steigende erträge und steigende preise
und die jeweils stärker als im
ökologischen bereich
was sozusagen dazu führt dass die schere
der unterschied der
einkommensmöglichkeiten singt hinzu
kommen dass die politik in den letzten
jahren im ökolandbau wird ja eben auch
gefördert weil sie eben ökologische
leistungen erbringen der ökologische
landbau dass diese prämien runtergesetzt
aufgesetzt und dort keine
verlässlichkeit ist auch das schafft
eine nicht so gute stimmung auf die rund
12.000 euro jährlich an eu-subventionen
verzichtet stefan rücke jetzt gerne
seitdem er wieder umgestellt hat haben
sich seine erträge mehr als verdoppelt
doch bereut er seine entscheidung
also manchmal schon wenn ich dann bin
ich die rechnung sie für für den
mineraldünger sich dann im frühjahr
bekommen hast dann habe ich das schon
oft gedacht na ja ob das nun wirklich
der richtige weg war
aber jetzt wo ich die ernte sie das ist
schon der richtige weg gewesen
aufzuhören und eben die ganze
videokontrolle 23 tage vorbereitungszeit
vor der kontrolle steht das sind fällt
einfach jetzt alles das habe ich im
moment nicht zufrieden damit wie es
gemacht
künftig sollen in deutschland 20 prozent
der flächen ökologisch bewirtschaftet
werden
so will es die bundesregierung stefan
röpke wird nicht mehr dabei sein
obwohl er bio bauer mit leib und seele
war